it is funny when you get this is just a
tangent but when you get to hold an
iconic instrument yeah if you've had
that experience I'm sure you have where
it's it's uh you know a famous guitar
that you get to hold on no if I actually
have but my friends we did a song with
Willie and
um before he got to the studio his his
tech asked a friend of mine to tune it
or to hold it and play it while they
while they did the sound and if my
friend was pretty excited to play
trigger I would imagine yeah that would
be pretty freaky I think uh I've seen
just over the years well through Danny
Harrison I was in England and went by
his house which was his dad's house
obviously and he he uh let me he showed
me and he's acting like it oh you know
do you want to hold the 1963 Gretch Duo
Jet that my dad played in the cavern oh
wow and I was thinking I shouldn't touch
it it's like I will defile it and then
you realize it's a guitar yeah and it
needs to be played it wants to be played
it wants to be well actually the guitar
did see me and say no not here
[Laughter]
that's so funny actually you're
reminding me I have played a very famous
piano and I got to go to Friar Park and
met George Harrison and Danny was there
and Olivia when I first reconnected with
my dad actually I was kidding I was 18
years old we finally reconnected and we
got very close over the years after that
so it was a a great thing and I remember
I landed in London to go visit them for
the first time in a long time and
they're like we're going to George's
house for dinner so just take a nap
clean up I was like okay whatever I
didn't know we were going to George
Harrison's house oh my God who is this
George anyway I was kind of oblivious
you know I was just jet lagged and young
and we get there and he he was so sweet
yeah and he was so happy to see me and
my dad reconnect as well and um and he
idolized your dad he did clearly it was
your dad changed his life yeah I mean it
was it was kind of a crazy night and I
was half half jet-lagged through the
whole thing but he um he asked me to
play for him because my dad told him
that I was this piano player and I was
like okay because I just was like you
know I knew who he was at that point of
course you played for George Harrison so
I wow I sat down at this piano which now
I know I didn't at the time but I think
it was one of John Lennon's pianos yes
and I've seen it because it when I was
there I think they moved it to it this
was in a different it's not in the house
when I saw it it's there's this other
place where they shot all the interviews
for the Anthology and it's got this hand
painting on it it's got painting like a
rainbow and these sort of psychedelic
stuff yeah I didn't know this at the
time and I was kind of just oblivious to
the whole meaning of the moment but I
sat down and I played an old Hoagy
Carmichael song called The Nearness of
You and he was so sweet and it was just
a very funny moment that I just now
remembered and he like I'm sure he loved
it yeah I mean he was kind about it I
don't know
if he hated it he pretended he loved it
you are Norah Jones
I was 18. and I know but if I had come
in at 18 and played a song on the piano
for for George Harrison it would have
gone very differently well I sang it too
so that that was kind of a funny yeah
yeah exactly luckily I didn't know the
instrument was so historic yeah it's
good not to know those I think so it's
better to just be oblivious yeah
um I'm kind of intrigued that when you
first started out before you had all
your success you were a lounge singer
and
for just a little bit you were a lounge
singer and I'm thinking
um you know let's say things hadn't
blown up for you do you do you think you
could have like made your peace with
being a lounge singer for a long time or
is that a tough gig I mean it's
something you know really know right you
can't go back I I wouldn't yeah I kind
of was a lounge singer but it was really
more like a restaurant than a lounge so
you're playing for people while they're
eating yeah and and usually they
wouldn't clap and nobody heard but the
gig was actually to just play piano but
since I sang I asked if I could bring a
little little amp and and sing like
every five songs or something and it was
actually the best practice I ever had
this is in college in Dallas and um I I
basically learned how to sing and play
at the same time because it's kind of a
coordination thing sure yeah so it was
it was great practice and every once in
a while the whole restaurant like one
person would just start clapping and
then slowly the whole restaurant would
start clapping
but then usually they weren't they
weren't clapping at all I
um oh man I will tell you that first of
all the the thing I hate the most in
comedy is when you have to
perform for people who are eating yeah
that's horrible and it doesn't matter
what stage you get to there's there are
benefits yeah where you they say okay go
on up and you have your jokes and you
have your riffs that you want to do and
you get up on stage and you hear the
distinct sound of of of silverware
hitting it you know clanking together
and then and then and people chewing and
I remember being at the uh there's a big
ballroom at the Waldorf Astoria and I
had to do benefits there a million times
when I was in New York and being up
there and the crowd doesn't even know
just a voice of God goes ladies and
gentlemen O'Brien and and people are
just getting there like plates are being
put down and served and people are
saying no no I said red not white yeah
and I walked upstage and there wasn't
even any sense that I was on stage yeah
and I go well anyway and I start to get
into my thing and a man was sitting
right in the front row oh just signed
and his back was to me and he was
cutting into his meat and he put it in
his mouth and he's chewing and then he
whipped his head around to look at who's
this annoying person at the podium
behind me and I just saw a chewing
unhappy face looking up at me that's not
great and I thought this this is I
don't want to perform for people eating
you can have like a no eating clause
I'll do it but not when they're eating
when they're eating directly before
dinner or after the plates have been
cleared but I will tell you this Nora I
am a person who if I'm anywhere if I'm
in a bar or restaurant and someone's
playing when they finish the song I
applaud yeah I don't care and sometimes
it's awkward because I get
self-conscious because if you're the if
I start applauding and no one else does
I think I'm making the situation worse
yeah especially if no one else does yeah
it's kind of weird and also you're
drawing attention to yourself well I
love that part oh okay I didn't know if
you like that
I go out I actually want to go out in a
t-shirt if it says I am burning O'Brien
and then parentheses it explains who
that is you start clapping in the middle
of the song yeah yeah
[Laughter]
on me
I just want to get a cockaroo while
we're here
[Applause]
thank you
I
just want to get a cockroach that's what
she said yeah exactly I've been getting
that all my life